how many day jobs have you had in your
life
I had three at the same time
I've had maybe I would say six day jobs
so far three at the same time and then
one after another hours retail data
entry computer a technician
and
a beer Runner
oh security guard small person
um you know non-profit raising money in
and then uh and then worked most of my
life my nine to five job at Ernst young
ey at that time as a computer fixer
fixed computers and
move that way up into engineering
network engineering analysis and then
went into Communications and branded
marketing
and while running my side Hustle
what's wrong with having a high paying
secure job
what's wrong
um
what's wrong would be that you don't get
to put all the time into the things that
you want to do
right like I want to be a full-time
filmmaker
but I got my business to run or you have
to or you have your nine to five job
that to make ends meet
um is that something wrong or is that
just real life you know
um
I don't know I I I struggle with that
question sometimes because I I think
that you know ideally you want to do
what you love to do but you still got to
take out the trash right and the trash
might be the job
right and but however
the reason why you get to do what you
love to do is because of the job
and so you can't trash on the job
because you know you get to do that so
it's kind of like you know
is that privileged is that like being
spoiled you know like in in the so in
the Buddhist world
it's not it's not about you know it's
you don't you don't
you you live to eat I mean you you you
eat to live not the other way around you
know you don't live to eat
so you survive it's about survival
and for us my survival is about
for me what I feel like I why I'm here
why why I'm given a lot of gifts in life
is to really help people and be
impactful and
otherwise I don't understand why why I
have these certain capabilities that is
very difficult for people to have you
know and so for me I think it's
um I think it's given to me to
the obvious thing is to help people
do you notice that when you were a kid
that you had these unique I did I knew
what I wanted to do when I was like 12
years old
and I went in this place of how do I
find how do I build value
you know where do I go to build value so
I started doing with piano being like
like being good at the piano okay I'm
sure if I was good at something like
that something's gonna happen all right
okay let me be good in sports you know
like community and stuff if I was good
in that maybe something's gonna happen
um and then as I would get older I was
like I was always looking for the thing
that was going to be impactful
and I I was always I just stuck to music
I don't know why I start to create it
forms formats and um
yeah I was never confused of what I what
uh in life like like what I wanted to do
I just knew that I wanted to do
something that was impactful and it was
in the creative format
so you were 12 you were living in New
Jersey and you knew
there was a different life
for you and 100
um
you know I'm you know like I me being
Asian you know my parents were Asian
family and so we are about trying to
please our parents that's our culture
um and I went into what I wanted to
apply for college I went to Rutgers
University I only applied to one college
you know most people applied multiple
colleges in case they'll go in I just
had this hunch that look I'm gonna get
into Rutgers
and then I'm gonna I'm gonna do I'm
gonna do my music Major
and then I'm gonna get a computer job
during my music Major because because I
just felt like you didn't need to have a
me if like a computer degree to get a
computer job
so you again strategy you you knew that
you saw the big picture Okay saw the big
picture so I I just wanted to know that
I just knew that if I needed to get a
degree
that at least during that time that a
degree was valued right but they didn't
care what kind of degree you got they
just want to know that you got through
four years of college or five years of
college
and then when you take on the job the
specialty you're going to learn the
specialty at the job
so that's what I did so I finished in
music
it was easy for me
and got a computer job at an accounting
firm
and it kind of worked out it was like it
was just
that thing you know it was weird
this is Windows operating system we're
working on okay yeah yeah Windows 95 or
so yeah yeah yeah yeah okay and so you
could do all that and then is there are
there patterns to Computer Engineering
and working with computers that are
similar to music or no
um
no I wouldn't say there's any familiar I
think it was just
to me it was just a job
you know it was a job that I
I knew I could do well because I was
just kind of wired for that for the
computer stuff and then I knew that I
was you know I wanted to do the music
for the impact stuff right
um I knew that I wasn't gonna work my
way up
the latter like going to the music
industry and that was just it was just
different way of thinking about it I was
you know and kind of very similar to
what I think about in films too I was
like um I'm not gonna I didn't go to
film school and I will do my my feature
films
and when did you leave
your day job when were you basically
your own boss in 2013
um
I had so I saw the situation is this I I
in 2009 I had pivoted into the film
industry you know did three short films
in a single year I did photography did
everything that was about film stuff the
requirement for films I had the prereqs
of talking to artists already which is
like my actors you know like to be able
to communicate to I knew I had the skill
sets for that
um
and then what I did is I went into the
wedding industry because I saw an
opportunity to have a lucrative business
where I don't have to work in it
um and so I went and built that business
and in 2013 we went from doing uh like
from 12 weddings to 80 weddings in a
single year where to a point where I
didn't have to be on the job anymore so
when I did that when I knew that I could
make money without
having to work my nine-to-five job
then somehow somehow the film the film
Project set what came to my you know
just kind of jumped in my lap the wall
before Mickey
positioning positioning positioning when
you quit your day job did you leave room
to come back and how did you quit okay
I'm gonna probably sell ey on this one
Erickson Y'all Gonna sell them on this
they are all for about people wanting to
build a better career for themselves
that's why their slogan is about
building a better working world
and they lived to that so they knew I've
always had my side hustle my side
businesses they always asked me about it
how is your business doing why I'm
working for them
and so
um I had an office job and as long I did
the dead job of being fair to them
um they were going to respect me for
that but when it came to the point where
I couldn't do the job anymore because I
was getting so busy with my my side
business
I said look it's not fair to you guys
you guys been fair to me I need to quit
they said well you can't quit I just
gave you this high level position I was
like I was an engineer webcaster for
them at the time
um so what we're going to do is we're
going to just give you a contract
so you guys so then we'll pay you but
you could do Your Own Thing full-time
but when we need you you're there for us
okay good deal no problem and that's
that's how that happened
I would say yeah I mean some people call
it luck and but I call it positioning
you know I was like I positioned myself
in the place where I was very invaluable
to them
is being is you know like this is like
this for for the filmmakers they need to
understand how to build value
the directors of diamond dozen cinema
times Diamond doesn't the positions are
diamond doesn't
how do you build how do you be in a
position that where they cannot say no
to you
but do you think everybody has that in
them you can lead a horse to water you
can't make a drink
so you can you can provide people
instructions but not everybody wants to
do that yeah but you you have it in you
I think everyone has it in them I just
think that they might not be honest with
themselves
you know what I'm saying like do you
like I look I I went I became the iron I
became an agile Professor for another
University and I teach I taught like 60
different students
and
I would say 99 of them went to film
School
but they had an idea wanting to be a
filmmaker but they don't want to be a
filmmaker
you know what I'm saying it's not like
they
they got a camera but they're not making
a film trying to make a film every
weekend
they're now working hard enough to win
you know what I'm saying if I come from
the background where the only reason why
I ca I was able to have
these opportunities is because I work my
tail off for it
18 20 hour days I go to work from nine
to five nine to six eat to eat for 30
minutes we're from seven to four or five
o'clock in the morning do it seven days
a week my vacations were three weeks of
vacation were going to work my business
I would never take a day or I don't
travel I don't go to clubs I don't party
I don't do any of that it was just it
was a straight whatever I was focused on
I would just do it
and it might not be directly to films
but it was leading to films it was all
about positioning and getting yourself
in the place that I thought was well
something might work or might not work
but the fact that I was working to my
towards my career for that
I don't see people doing that
if you really I look at if you really
really really want it
you know you do everything you can to
you can do everything you can to win
if you're not you don't really want it
you know I mean
I don't know how else to explain that to
people like oh can you work 18 hour days
do you want enough to work 18 hours can
you do it without sleep can you do when
you just have to just knock on the floor
and sleep on the floor
is that what you're willing to do right
why is life better when you're the boss
I am a control freak
uh life is better because you get to
shape your future the way you see fit
um I'm a Steve Jobs fan because he
thinks like that too he says when you
start
seeing that you can start poking to the
world and start shaping it the way you
want to shape it that that you realize
that humans are the one that created the
rules
you're a human too that you can create
your own rules
then you can create the rules that will
shaped to something that you want to see
then you have to be the boss to do that
being the boss allows you to have that
type of control and
and boss doesn't mean that you're
bossing people boss means control for
yourself